the fact that people argue with me on
this reading thing and people argue with
me about mentors no just use your own
gut feeling is that how you learn
English when you were 2 years old you
use your gut feeling to start
conjugating verbs no you learn from
other people people really only buy one
thing they bind his stories
that's why Steve Jobs and Apple did well
people buy this story of Apple this was
my bed right here
I had a bunk beds because sometimes
there'd be another guy working and this
was the toilet the bucket I bet you can
still all they change the floor there
was a hole in the floor and a bucket was
underneath need motivation what had
nothing with believe nation
he's ty Lopez and here's my take on his
top fifty rules for success
enjoy okay let's kick it off with rule
number one increase your sense of
urgency life is very short
I see people going oh I'm 22 I only have
you know I have all the world in front
of it you don't first of all tomorrow's
not guaranteed but more importantly the
age with which people are starting to
become entrepreneurs I read there's a
kid he made a nuclear power plant in San
Francisco he's 17 years old
that's your new competitor so increase
your sense of urgency as an intangible
rule number two practice I need to
practice remember before the day comes
you gotta practice you cannot be
standing at the free-throw line
playing professional basketball in the
seventh game of the NBA championship and
hope right then you're gonna be practice
practice is too late Larry Bird used to
put the great basketball player he used
to shoot whatever a thousand free-throws
8:00 in the morning my friend Don ravine
trains a lot of the pro basketball
players LeBron James he trains he trains
Durant
Kobe Chris Paul and he said these guys
are up when everybody else is sleeping
they're practicing so everything you
want is gonna entail a good bit of
practice rule number three protect what
you already have so the second thing you
have to do is people have to understand
insurance and I'm not just talking about
life insurance or health or I'm saying
you have to protect what you already
have so some people like Warren Buffett
says you don't have to get rich once so
when you do well and you make money have
insurance buy save some of it for a
rainy day that's insurance I did a video
on it like that was the most important
because there was a few times in my life
where I got like really I'll say really
high up your pyramid you know right and
then feel bad yeah and I feel bad I I
did a video of it maybe I'll put a link
in it into the description three times I
went like a way of the fear me and fell
back yeah I didn't insurance well now
you now you can tell people don't fur
and
Mark Cuban who became a billionaire he
owns the Dallas Mavericks and different
stuff
he sold a company are like a sports
radio program and he was brought shares
of Yahoo and at the when he got so they
paid him all these shares which were
worth a lot of money at the time but you
know shares can go up and down so he had
one mentor a financial advisor who said
don't listen you should buy insurance on
this so there's a way to do that with
stock options and sure enough those
shares of Yahoo had been paid in dropped
to almost worthless but he had locked in
the value with insurance so he's still
the billionaire we know now so lock in
what you have rule number four increase
your courage increase your courage
harden up a little bit take a cold
shower don't always take a warm shower
acclimate your mind and your body to
doing things that are harder you know
one of my friends who's one of the most
successful people in the young startup
but made a billion dollar valuation on a
company of five years whenever we're
talking about new ideas we're gonna do
next
if I say oh that's gonna be easy why
don't we do that he says time there's no
money in what's easy focus on these
intangibles you know the ability to have
a ton of courage also if you want to
have more confidence check out my 250
for confidence series it's free the link
is in the description below the reason
people aren't patient is they value
other people's opinions too much you
have to go build self-confidence the
minute you begin to get external in your
life worrying about what other people
think about you right you vote you've
lost all control you and it never fills
you up rule number five get a hold of
something and hang on to it he said the
secret to advice I mean the sacred to
success is get hold of something and
hang on just hang on
if somebody wants it hang on to it it's
worth as much to you as it is to anybody
who wants it I have to think in the
world now or everybody's idea of a
business is make a business I'm gonna
buy a piece real say I want to flip it
I'm gonna do it one week later I'm gonna
buy a stalking short sale this guy had a
completely different approach you get a
hold of something and hang on to it and
if you look at some of the most
successful people in the world
they follow that strategy Bill Gates
gave up very little shares in Microsoft
he owned I think 60% of it even at its
peak he may have sold since then but he
got ahold of something and didn't didn't
let go and he says and again that's the
opposite of mentality and most people
have Warren Buffett has the same thing
he buys businesses that he would want to
hold on to forever you got to get good
we talked about this getting good at one
thing but this guy was saying I've heard
this this is a new member I said you
gotta create voices in your head this is
a voice this Jack Simplot I want they
even put on the back of the grab a hole
to something and hang on if you don't
have something to grab a hold of you
better freak out and find something to
grab hold on it could be an occupation
it could be a movement it could be a
charity you could be a business it can
be an invention it could be a piece of
art but grab hold of something and do
not let go now make sure you grab all of
the right thing because if grabbing a
wrong thing you're in for some trouble
but have some investment don't spend all
your cash so that you when a good deal
comes up you have the money to buy if
you're an artist if you're farmer if
you're a actor or whatever you're gonna
need some cash don't spend the tall and
get a hold of something rule number six
have extraordinary imaginative vision
people as successful have extraordinary
imaginative vision and Elon Musk calls
it a more complicated term which is
arguing from first cause it's not
analogy so here's what arguing from
analogy or not having an extraordinary
management division let's say you're in
a horrible place you were sleeping in
your car yeah I was super on couch
someone born and get us someone born in
poor part India if you argue from
announced re arguing for monologist
doing bad right I'm doing bad therefore
I'm gonna always do bad
that's arguing from analogy and that's
not having imaginative vision the people
who make it are the people who do the
opposite they go I'm gonna argue from
first causes I'm gonna say
has anybody ever written a ridden risen
up from the ashes out of the ghetto or
from a couch or from the car
the answer is we all know that story so
if somebody else did it then if you use
extraordinary creative imagination then
why can't you do it - and that's arguing
from first causes that's what allowed
Elon Musk to make Tesla spaceships
SolarCity so for all of us we get stuck
when we argue from analogy well you know
last time I started a business it failed
last time I trusted somebody they
betrayed me well that's good that's
arguing from a now justice saying
because it happened before it's gonna
happen it doesn't always work that way
sometimes you do it better you double
down on your brain you learn from the
mistakes of others and your mistakes and
the next thing you create something new
and that's where wealth come from not
just wealth in your bank account wealth
of happiness love health everything you
want rule number seven change your
mindset change your life remember change
your mind change your life everybody
wants to change life but you have to
change your mind humans are different
because we have powerful minds and
sometimes I gets us in trouble but if
you pull it off right it can bring you
those things that you need in life those
things that you're missing you know
everybody wants the good life like I say
my TEDx talk everybody wants the good
life but not everybody gets the good
life because most people aren't willing
to do this stuff that it takes then I
willing to put in the time put in the
grind rule number eight have aha moments
should not be a 450-pound person making
fun of other people for being overweight
just focus on yourself and learn from
the world don't take that attitude of
huh oh really
nobody great is gonna prove their point
to you for the most part they're gonna
say what they have to say this guy's
dead he does not care what you think
about his book if you're able to go
through this and glean three things that
change your life forever then that's
great for you so have that attitude of
ah look for aha moments at every moment
in your day I started keeping a
billboard with my staff and I'm
like guys it's getting lopsided look at
all the and I put a little mark every
time I had a good idea for the business
and I'm like I want your side more than
mine there's no rule that I have to have
all the good ideas be innovative be
innovative read books like this fine
little innovations for your own life
rule number 9 be quick but not in a
hurry
most people are patiently impatient
which I'm pretty sure is a recipe for a
horrible life
what you have to be a
the opposite it sounds identical to be
impatiently patient versus patiently
impatient but it makes all the
difference in the world so I wish
someone had Romy said look at I'm like
John wouldn't say be quick but not in a
hurry 99% of people do is they act as if
they have all the time in the world so
people are like patient you see people
you're like well when are you gonna make
your move on life they're like well you
know I've gotta wait for a few things
together so they're patient but then
when real opportunities arise that they
can identify instead of patiently
waiting and building them step by step
like sculpting a sculpture they hastily
jump into them they don't put the hard
work in they don't build a foundation in
the structure so that's when they are
impatient what I suggest you try
is the exact opposite freak out if
you're not getting the dreams that you
wish you had
right so freak out like so today don't
even be don't even say Oh tomorrow I'm
gonna get good at this
freak out now but then patiently filled
so I can just go through a million
things in my life where I felt pretty
one of them is setting far-off goals
when you set a 10-year goal you're just
basically giving yourself an excuse to
eight years into it you're like well I'm
still on track as I got
two years more no look
people write big things make most always
immediate but immediat
[Music]
action towards the bowl once you
immediately freaked out you immediately
take action then step number two
impatiently moves through cycles and
then and I recommend you can go through
a full cycle Peter Drucker says a good
enough time that things can kick in
but it's not so long that you lose the
predictive power of goals goals are
trying to get predictive power therein I
think lies the happy needs you're
setting your 67 day goals which are
really fast you're watching us at
midnight start at midnight what anybody
informant make a slow be quick but not
in a hurry there's this myth of the solo
entrepreneur I'm one good idea I'm gonna
go out or I'm gonna come up with his one
invention I was just reading a book I
think it was by craig Venter or one of
these big biotech guys and he said you
know there's this huge myth that they're
great breakthroughs happen from one
person having an individual moment of
genius the Steven Johnson talks about
this a lot in his book where good ideas
come from almost all great ideas come
from some collaborative effect and so
the best way to create a collaborative
effect is for you to take what you know
and clone it out to three or four people
or five people or at least one person
even if you let's say for example
hypothetically you could get two people
to know 50% of what you know to be 50%
as effective as you well guess what two
people at 50% is another one of you and
you look out at the world and you go man
all the things that could be
accomplished if I just could didn't have
to sleep and I could work 24 hours a day
or I could go out there Joel Salatin
told me that when he was here that I I
don't have people sleep with all the
opportunities and so Joel my first
mentor he created his protege was his
son Daniel who now runs the operations
and frees Joel up to be in the big
picture and the company their farm is
more successful polyphase farming Joel's
able to do other things you have to be
able to do that rule number 11 find
mentors the thought that people argue
with me on this reading thing and people
argue with me about Mentors
no just use your own gut feeling is that
how you learn English when you were 2
years old you use your gut feeling to
start conjugating verbs no you learn
from other people you learn manners you
learn language you learn all things
valuable you learn to draw
from another person so it doesn't make
sense you learn life so books are just
the mentors who maybe are dead now you
wanna learn about Steve Jobs you know
live to teach you but you can learn
through accumulated wisdom and that's
what trust me
I meet I very few powerful businessman
I've ever met
don't read a lot Warren Buffett who I
think's the best businessman by far in
the world because doesn't see has 75
companies that he pretty much runs 200
billion in revenue he reads eight hours
a day
he reads 600 he said he slowed down in
his old age he only reads 500 pages a
day Bill Gates goes on reading vacations
Mark Zuckerberg just start started a
reading once a week book club on
Facebook and already got a couple
million fathers and now with audiobooks
there's no excuse you got YouTube videos
let this thing run in the background
like you want to become like a
supercomputer you just download smart
crap from smart people and you pick and
choose like some people are like Thai I
don't agree with everything you say I'm
like good I don't agree with everything
I said like a year later I'm like wait I
was wrong I see people making fun of the
Kardashians I'm like you gonna make fun
of the Kardashians look Kylie Jenner the
youngest Kardashian in the last 18
months has done four hundred million
dollars in revenue on lipstick kits and
various make up things with Kylie
cosmetics put that in perspective
Lauria maybelline massive brands it took
them 50 years as an organization with
thousands of employees to do a Kylie
Jenner did by herself at 20 at 18 you're
gonna laugh at the Kardashians do you
have to agree with everything on
Kardashians no but like Abraham Lincoln
said I learned from everybody even if
sometimes it's what not to do so you can
just go into the Kardashians
reverse-engineer their success go I like
this I like this I like this I don't
like that then leave out what you don't
like rule number 12 work smarter I know
single mom my mom was a single mom all
around us family single moms people
trying to put food on their table
working two three jobs is the answer for
them to just work harder or is it to
work smarter work hard or work smart
because they're different I'm always
reminded of this
story that my mentor Alan nation told me
he said tie and I don't know if there's
a true sport but it gets the point
across
there was a plane flying over South
America it crash-landed and it was full
of all these engineers all these hard
workers and the hard workers got out and
were so machetes and they all grabbed a
machete and they begin to hack their way
through the jungle chop chop chop chop
chop flurries of activity boy they were
work it hard but they forgot something
don't ever confuse flurries of activity
with accomplishment activity doesn't
always equal achievement so they were
chopping through and luckily for them
one person got out of the plane instead
of working hard went on climbed up a big
tree and looked out and surveyed the
landscape and yelled down to the group
and said hey guys you're working hard
but you're going the wrong direction
you're going deeper into the jungle the
city for our escape is the other way you
see what's move civilization forward is
not just hard work go to any hotel got
any restaurant the hardest-working
people there are working their ass off
and they're still not getting ahead
there's still not equality in pay
there's still people making massive
amounts who don't work nearly as hard as
the working-class know what's gets you
ahead is leverage in fact it's the exact
opposite what you want to do is how to
figure out how to work half the time and
get twice as much done so that you could
take a vacation so that you can in paint
a painting and have time some downtown
so you can go on vacation with your
family so you can just lay out on a
beach and just look at nature and enjoy
life you want to just grind yourself
into the ground go ahead but the people
that get ahead are not just grinders
they are not the grind is necessary
worked as necessary but it's never a
goal it's a necessity
the goal is very different the goal of
life is not to breathe breathing as a
necessity the goal of life is to enjoy
your life to do something important you
breathe because you must you work
because you must but you never say well
you know what I you know why I'm here is
just a breathe no you're not here just
the work working harder doesn't always
change the game rule number 13 find your
motivation most people procrastinate
because they don't feel confident that
the what they're doing really motivates
them if a really motivate motivated you
it what you wouldn't procrastinate it's
like
fourteen-year-old kid that the mom and
dad can't get the kid to do anything but
the kids motivated play video games
Kittel ride his bike across town to buy
a video game and come back like so
there's motivation there the parents
just don't wanna find it and as you grow
you have to know how to find deep within
yourself that motivation and once you
have motivation you have no problem with
procrastination rule number 14 be a
perfectionist people you have to know
how to double check your work it's that
simple
it doesn't mean you're always a
perfectionist but it means when it's
important when you're a pilot of an
airplane double check before you go bait
if you get on a plane you hear the
pilots double checking the co-pilot
going you know hydraulics and the guy
goes hydraulics but and that's why
planes don't crash and it's called Six
Sigma it's three defects per million
your goal in business and in life on the
important things is to make three
mistakes per million transactions in the
only way you do that is by being a
perfectionist in terms of double-check
this rule number 15 have thick-skinned a
lesson in branding whenever trying to
brand yourself or any company if you
change your brand from what it used to
be at a rig right away you can get
resistant so most people when they get a
little resistance because most people
have thick skin and then they stop but
over time if you keep branding yourself
in the new brand then eventually it
catches on like I used to not have much
fitness stuff so when I fire to start
putting Fitness stuff people are like
what is all this Fitness now eventually
people just associate that with you and
they forget there was a time when you
didn't do it so that's a good tip on
branding you have to have to pick enough
skin because it's kind of like when
Facebook changed every time they changed
their interface people go nuts oh I hate
this but then three months later they
can't remember those one and then when
you change you a new one they say no we
like the one before but that one before
is the one they hated it
because it was a change from the version
of you know one before but Mark
Zuckerberg smarter than people that's
why it just keeps changing it whatever
is better and then people eventually
like it
same when Instagram changed their logo
snapchat changed their you know people
always a lot of people have low OH
meaning low openness to new experience
they automatically hate anything new
rule number 16 invest in yourself and
I'm telling you becoming a learning
machine and a person who invests in the
cell works I invest at least a hundred
thousand dollars a month in my own
education literally a hundred G's a
month not a year I got a CPA back that
number up I've shown it it's it's
obvious to if you watch my snapchat
traveling mentors coaches consultants
that I pay and I've been doing that for
years and it's funny the more I invested
myself every year my income has gone up
massively some people go oh well I'm not
gonna pay for stuff I'm just gonna
google it well go ahead but I'm telling
you there is a magic it investing in
yourself people get it invested in real
estate it's good oh okay I do that
invest in stock market that's good I buy
land i oh are investing by businesses
it's all good but nothing touches the
ROI on investing in my own brain rule
number 17 be organized the next one is
organization I can't tell you how much
better my life is and anybody watching
this will be if you wake up every single
day and you take ten minutes I have
yellow notepad sitting all around my
house I got that from Bill Gates Bill
Gates bill and Microsoft at 17 by
locking himself in a hotel room was six
yellow notepads and he wrote out the
whole basic code for boss and things
that built Microsoft okay he became the
richest man in the world 18 years
straight because he was organized enough
to lock himself in a room and think
through his day and so what I try to do
and whenever I do this I have a great
day whenever I don't I notice it be
organized a little bit 10 minutes I
actually have this little couch thing
outside of my shower and I put a notepad
buy it I take a shower when I wake up I
walk over to that
sit there and I just write out I mean it
can be as little as three main projects
you want to get done that day
rule number 18 optimize for the right
things I can go back time the one thing
I'm gonna tell it to right now it's this
you can only pick one thing that you
want out of life and if you pick the
wrong thing you'll never really be
successful let me back up
my mentor Joe South had said the worst
thing in life is to get older and
realize you got good at the wrong thing
and I see people that are very wealthy
but I don't admire I live here in
Beverly Hills this billionaire is all up
and down the street doesn't mean I would
trade lies for in fact the best test is
I called the exchange test would you
trade lives and the reason that almost
anybody I meet I wouldn't trade life for
them it's not because they're not smart
not because they're not good people it's
because one simple thing they're
optimizing for the wrong thing so let's
say you say I want to be entrepreneur
that's not something you should optimize
for that's ridiculous
here's why you have one life maybe we'll
go to heaven or hell laughter maybe
there's an act like maybe there are
maybe there isn't I've never been there
so I can't speak on but I can tell you
you get one chance on this planet and if
you optimize for an entrepreneur what
about your health what about love what
about happiness I'm a miserable
entrepreneurs that are fat out of shape
I don't want to be them I know I do that
not had a close friend of mine but a
friend of an entrepreneur friend this
guy's a billionaire but he's so fat II
can't
I bet is two billion dollars as a
private 747 jet so what I want to be him
know he optimized for the wrong thing he
optimized to make two billion dollars
but he forgot why would you want to have
two billion dollars a video on how
health I always remember what Joel
Salatin said nothing worse in life then
realizing you've got good at the wrong
thing that guy got good at the wrong
thing it's irrefutable you cannot argue
with that
why would you give your health up to
gain money there's a saying that when
people are young they lose their health
to get wealth and when they're old they
use their wealth to get back their
health it's a circular logic and
circular in this case is illogical it's
stupid you are stupid mostly if I could
go back in time I realize most people
are lost literally most people are lost
out of it I'm talking about the people
who write you know I got the biggest
book club in the world
I know top authors and all these people
they might be smart in one specific
domain but if you look at their life I
wouldn't exchange for it there's a few
people that I've met that when I look
back on my life even though one of them
Arnold Schwarzenegger not everything but
he was healthy he was strong he changed
the world he made gyms hot gyms come
from unfortunately he made this table
all the gyms all over marriages from
Arnold I'm scorching now other people
worked on it but not like him he
motivated people who came self-made
millionaire before 30
he wanted to action acting's in art he
was an artist he became you know maybe
it wasn't the best actor in the world
he's not bad I was actually in his
kitchen a couple months ago just like
this I mean him talking smoking cigars
he's a good actor like I said he might
not be you know daddy award but he got
the good life his son was there his kids
were there at his house he's happy he's
friends you got social life you got to
have health love love happiness if you
at any point optimize it for anything
that doesn't involve all four of them
you're making the biggest mistake in the
world
rule number 19 build an elite team here
that you got to do to build a team
first of all number one you got to
realize no one ever did anything big
without an elite team around them
Bill Gates said he never did anything
alone
except take tests he said he had Steve
Ballmer he had Paul Allen he had a
hundred thousand employees behind him to
build Microsoft in the biggest company
in the world same with Facebook the same
with all same with Elon Musk that
realization will help you put in the
time and motivate you to have an effort
to want to put in the effort number two
thing is you have to train formally
everybody knows they need to train their
employees but they do it in a very
informal haphazard way which doesn't
work
what does formal training look like well
maybe a little bit like a classroom a
dedicated room that your employees go
into a dedicated time pen and paper
drills exercises quizzes
testing for retention
then number three you got to look over
their shoulder because once you do the
formal training
you can't expect memory retention to be
perfect so it must be continued over the
shoulder style training my main hope is
that that you'll take away the concept
of a formal training program most
entrepreneurs train very haphazard
leaving train only in crisises well
that's not going to cut it the only
train during crisis is they guess what
your blood pressure is gonna be through
the roof and you're only putting out
fires prevent fires prevent fire prevent
fires so you should have at least a
three time a week training program for
airports
it was really I want to play this should
feel formal there should be a curriculum
tool there should be understanding when
they walk in the classroom or the
training room what they'll learn for
that day there should be evaluations so
don't just be like most of the small
business owners that don't have an elite
team because they never took the time
they never understood you
iliza training and I never followed up
on the train rule number 20
have fun I'm back here in my garage just
got this new Lamborghini but you know
what I'm more proud of voting YouTube
video sorry about your pause yes sir in
your house yes sir sorry sorry sir uh uh
the bushes I trimmed them though I
trimmed them look how clean this thing
looking right now okay sorry sir I got
it going to lose my job
rule number 21 take some pain
I started Google AdWords in 2001 okay I
was I got lucky I just stumbled and I
was one of the first people to ever use
online advertising I was in I think the
second month Google AdWords launched and
there was no YouTube videos there was no
Perry Marshall books there was there was
nothing you just kind of wasted money to
learn now we're the most spoiled
generation everything this computer on
this phone iPhone 7 is more powerful
than the first rocket that put man on
the moon that cost billions of dollars
now we get that for under a thousand
bucks and people are still like I'm lost
yes your loss sit down and then open up
Safari and go how to do Google ads and
you're gonna come up let's see what I
come up with AdWords they have their own
tutorial word stream jump if I you got
some paid stuff then you have some free
stuff on HubSpot if you sit in a chair
Charlie Munger calls it assiduity put
your ass in a chair sit there and focus
without being you know the average
American right now the average first in
the world our attention span has dropped
to five seconds the sad news is the
average goldfish has 6 seconds we're now
competing with goldfish and the goldfish
are winning so if you don't have
assiduity to sit down breed there is no
solution for you you will always be poor
because you'll always be beat by
somebody who's willing to sit in the
chair is there a way for people to build
that discipline yes pain and that's why
I'm not a big believer in delusion
no you asked me one of the rewiring
things we have to do in this world I'll
tell you one you ever heard this myth
everything happens for a reason so just
accept it well there's kind of truth to
that if I jump off a building and break
my legs yes everything happened for a
reason
the reason was gravity like that's why
you break your legs and physics legs
brittle concrete not brittle so that but
people interpret everything happens for
a reason be like whoa I was meant to
learn from that thing and then BS read
Richard Dawkins The Selfish Gene one of
the most important books written in the
last century
he says organisms that only learn
through trial and error lose to
organisms that can learn through other
people's a trial endure is anybody here
we got a little live audience anybody
here ever had to be hit by a car to
learn to look both ways I did it I kind
of learned from just somebody telling me
big car two tons velocity smash dead and
I now always look both ways so if your
myth is that the only way you're gonna
learn is just through massive mistakes
in trial and error you have a read
Richard Dawkins book how does pain allow
somebody to get more disciplined okay so
going back to that myth of when you see
your life and any time there should be
pain you go no no no it was just how was
meant to be no look yourself in the
mirror sometimes and go you know why I'm
not happy it's because I didn't listen
ten years ago and I got in the wrong
career you know I'm not happy because I
married the wrong damn person it wasn't
meant to happen yes everything happens
for a reason
you made a bad choice but it didn't have
to be that way and the second you build
up pain and this by the way is not my
opinion if you talk to guys like dr.
David buss top ten most cited
psychologist in history okay he's one of
my main mentors he told me I said do
adults change like we do all this
self-help videos in podcast I said am I
wasting my time he goes yeah kind of I
said why he said well after 25 it's very
hard to teach old dogs new tricks by the
way that's why I've changed
most of my stuff targets people 18 to 25
that's why I do snapchat and all that
because there's hope for 18 to 25 oh now
if you're over 25 before you get
depressed he told me but I have good
news for you time I said what he said
adults learn through massive trauma so
you will learn you have to let in some
trauma into your life and that's rough
but no pain no gain
like if you are 100 pounds overweight
and you want to be able to play
basketball here's my news for you
everything happened for a reason you got
fat cause you ate too much and you
didn't exercise so welcome to the gym in
the first year is gonna be hell but that
pain hopefully will reprogram your brain
that every time you want to eat that
nasty thing go wait I don't want to go
through that pain again so I think one
of the myths of societies we won't let
pain in we just excuse it all the way
like nah that wasn't meant to happen
oh you wasted 20 years of life married
the wrong person in the wrong career no
Tom it wasn't too happy where's the
people who go you you've wasted 20 years
and you will never get it back you
better go in your room and cry and the
truth is you only learn as an adult
unfortunately most people can only
change with mass and trauma rule number
22 hustle I want to show you what it
means to give sweat equity that if you
don't have any money start with sweat
equity meaning go work for somebody else
use your time energy to make them money
that's what I did I'm here at Joel
Salatin my first mentors farm and he
said if you want to work for me you can
live in this little cabin and it didn't
have a toilet what had a bucket so and
it had no heat or no water
this was my bed right here I had a bunk
beds because sometimes there'd be
another guy working and this was the
toilet the bucket
I bet you can still they change the
floor there was a hole on the floor and
a bucket was underneath nightstand here
and I put a cup of water in it to drink
and we'd sleep in sleeping bags and when
I woke up it was a always an ice ice
that
you know it's cold in the morning you
reach over like the whole thing goes you
can't start out at the top you start out
at the bottom how the gang goes the
natural order of things
rule number 23 have a map of success the
third thing that you got to know is you
have to have a map of success so think
about you know in the olden days age to
bury treasure and to find it they would
have a map and if you didn't have that
map you could spend all the hard work
all the time all the effort all the
labor you wanted you never would find
the treasure and the school system
failed us let's just face it elementary
school junior high high school I'm not
saying all schools bad but I'm saying
there's things that didn't teach us we
didn't learn the proper tools and so we
weren't given the map to success and
that's why so many people are in debt
and why so many people are depressed and
why so many people have financial
trouble and so many people don't know
how to invest their money it comes from
a lack of a map and I want to give you a
map and that's part of why I've traveled
to 40 or 50 countries once I was
sleeping on that couch I found a mentor
Mike Stainback one thing led to another
I began Business Network and beginning
to travel I've been to you know New
Zealand and Japan and South America
Bolivia Chile Germany all these
countries around the world where I found
mentors who gave me a map they said here
ty here's what worked for us I remember
being in Germany with a guy who invited
me and and he was you know 30 years
older than me and he laid out how he
just told me we went on a walk back to
the hotel where I was staying I was
speaking doing a little business talk
there to his staff and he said town I
want to share with you what worked for
me I started at 12 years old and now I'm
70 years old and I want to show you what
worked for me Ty and I remember thinking
this guy's giving me the map what if
they had given me that map when I was 18
years old in school life would have been
so much easier if you have the map
you'll cut the learning curve rule
number 24 operate from a sense of logic
and duty you have a concept called never
be the [ __ ] of your own mind yes what
do you mean by that your own mind is
driven by deep evolutionary
drives so for example narcissism
is a protection mechanism right so your
mind wants to tell you you're amazing it
makes you its [ __ ] you have to override
that and go you know what I'm not that
amazing so let me go learn from amazing
people do you have methods for people to
do that because I think that's so
important so I tell people don't trust
everything that your mind says certainly
don't buy into all of your emotions just
because you have an emotion doesn't mean
you have to act in accordance with that
but how do you help people get over that
how do they overcome that I think humans
for the most part learn by osmosis so
it's hard to lecture people into success
but what you could do is you could
inspire people to understand this so for
example if you could if school system
could find all the 14 year olds and find
out what they admire in people right
it's the reason I show Lamborghinis
Ferraris it's got a lot of young
followers and you know what 19 year old
guys like Lamborghinis and Ferraris so I
show that part of my life because then
they listen to the other stuff so first
you got to lead by inspiration this has
been proven over you cannot pound stuff
into people's brain people actually do
the opposite when parents tell their
kids you've got to read
nobody reads but if I show a Lamborghini
and Ferrari which is the reward that
people want and then people go how do
you get it I said see all these books I
read them and put it then people I have
more school kids reading books I think
than anyone in history I don't say that
cocky I'm telling you it astounds me
because all I had to do was put up a
video with Lamborghinis right and so
being the [ __ ] of your own brain the
way you learn not to be the easiest way
is to be around people who aren't the
[ __ ] of their own brain like Joel
Salatin my first mentor I was lucky
enough right out of high school instead
of going to college I was with him at 19
and he is not a [ __ ] of his brain he's
a man of he wakes up and his life's more
like of duty he knows his duty and
whether it's hard or easy he plows
through it so everyday for example when
he had breakfast at 6:00 in the morning
on
farm he writes out an organized thing on
what he wants to do for the day when
you're the [ __ ] of your brain you go
I'm just gonna freewheel this day it's
very it's very hard to be organized
we're not dogs aren't organized you ever
see your dog organizing day so if you
wanna you can either act on the animal
side which is just a wing life or you
can operate from a sense of logic and
duty and so I learned somewhat I'm not
even as good as Joel to not be the [ __ ]
my mind by just being around for a while
and so that's the best way find somebody
that you look at them and you go this is
a person of discipline a motivation self
motivation they don't need external
motivation they're motivated from within
and spend all the time you can around
rule number 25 focus look the reason I
talk about social as it gives you
something to focus on but let me step
back so me you can't focus because let's
just face it you know social media makes
money by making you unfocused scientists
have studied how Facebook Instagram
Twitter all these apps have created
addictions and that's how why the people
who own them are the richest people in
the world now I use social media so I'm
not gonna say don't use social media
hello practical tip for 2018 turn off
all notifications on my phone I don't
have one notification on so if you have
an iPhone go to settings right here go
scroll down and notifications where is
my notifications right there turn
everything off look at mine show
previews never off off every single one
is off okay because I'm not a sucker I
use social media but social media is not
gonna use me I'll look at my facebook
when I want to not what Mark Zuckerberg
wants me to dopamine is released by
these apps it's literal physical
addictions created by these again you
can use social media but don't let it
use you so just a little practical thing
turn off the damn social media
locations and scram won't be there you
got to be reminded every time someone
deems you why are you too dumb that you
can't remember that Instagram a
notification if you can't remember it
that means it's probably not important
so he's the win-win situation you've got
more time and less distraction so focus
in 2018 I gave you the first thing to
focus on which is your social life
you're gonna have to focus you know I I
don't know how to draw a horse very well
but I'll just use a square with a head
every time I try to draw people are like
you're horrible at drawing so I am
horrible so horse I used to have a horse
and they put these things on the side of
horses right here they're called
blinders they don't really blind the
horse but they the horse can only see
straight ahead and the reason they do
that is because when you're out on the
road with a horse I live with the Amish
for two years if a car big car comes by
and the horse sees that out of the
corner of their eye they get scared and
I actually knew a guy he was driving
along the side of a road there was a
cliff on the edge that he didn't put the
blinders on that horse to focus the
horse a big truck was coming the horse
saw and kind of went like that inside
boo no he didn't die but he won't run
off the cliff got injured got thrown off
three four five six months
rehabilitating from their injury that's
a good metaphor for people you need to
put your blinders on and focus straight
ahead for 2018 what do you want out of
2018 more money more happiness more time
more freedom focus that brain on that
thing you can't be this is the average
person's brain in one second they want
to focus on let's say they're trying to
improve their business well they also
think about oh I got a DM oh okay
snapchat oh my mom's calling me oh I
wonder you know what happened next Game
of Thrones episode focus it can be as
simple as for example make a time when
you check all your social media I do it
I check try to check out once a day now
I'm in the business of social media so I
do check a little
about my personal side try to wake up
focus and I just go through all my half
one by one and get it out of way 15
minutes you know I I have a lot of
social media followers so it sometimes
takes me a little longer I got 13
million or something so I get a lot of
DMS but still I'm not gonna check them
all be real why just because you know so
if you got a thousand or two thousand
followers whatever five thousand I used
to have a hundred followers it took me
ten seconds a day and then I don't need
to check at the average person at work
is checking their email they said like
20 to 50 times an hour what a waste of
life man don't waste your life
rule number 26 find motivation you have
to know what motivates you and it's
different for different people you might
not care about cars you know you might
like travel or freedom from a
nine-to-five job whatever your thing is
find out your mix I wish the school
system had taught us this you know we
learned so many things that we don't
need in school you learn isosceles
triangles in the history of Mesopotamia
but what about how to be productive
overcome procrastination figure out what
motivates you for me it's a mix of a
little bit of materialistic things some
non materialistic things like freedom
and travel ability to help other people
help my family help charities that mix
gets me out of bed every day and you got
to know yours
rule number 26 let fear Drive you
there's this test called the dark triad
test which again anything important like
this nobody ever learned it in school
because schools are too stupid to take
real powerful science and apply it to
life but the dark triad is a worldview
barometer for everybody watch and you
can take it there's a different free
dark triad tests online it tests for
three main traits negative qualities
narcissism Machiavellianism and being
psychotic and I've personally tested
thousands and thousands of people it's
the most accurate test and what happens
narcissism okay one of the symptoms of a
narcissist it's not just like oh I like
to look in the mirror right that's what
we think of Marcy one of the classic
symptoms is very thin-skinned they're
always offended if you have a friend
that anything you say constructively
they fall apart
it's almost always narcissism even if
they're introverted there's multiple
forms there's introverted narcissism
extroverted exploitative all these
different sub facets of narcissism but
we live in a society that's very
narcissistic you're told like everybody
is a winner no not everybody's a winner
that's like saying everybody's blonde
there's a definition of what blonde is
blonde is like this yellowish hair so
you lose meaning when you start going
and everybody's blonde
well everybody doesn't win and the
sooner you wake up to that that biology
is ruthless man then you get a little
fear in you and when you get a little
fear in you you start listening because
if you're truly afraid you listen let a
little fear come in and Drive you in
motivate you rule number 27 don't get
stuck in the financial matrix at the
house here a Warren Buffett one of the
richest billionaires in the world he
bought this house in 1958 one of the
reasons most people call financial
matrix is then I'll teach you in school
you should invest in things that don't
appreciate you know so he does have a
house and houses real estate so it's
somewhat good investment but most of he
makes 200 billion dollars a year cash
flow not all net but he makes that
investing in businesses he does some
real estate it's what you got to do or
else like I said people trapped in the
financial matrix the financial matrix is
basically where you work for somebody
and you never break free so you're like
this slave and so you have to have
create excess cash you got to create
investments that work for you while you
sleep while he's sleeping in this house
that he bought in 1958 for probably I
don't know a hundred grand
he's his businesses are generating you
know 20 billion dollars a year form up
for them and you can replicate that on a
small scale you don't have to do twenty
billion but you have to learn how to
self educate yourself don't get stuck in
the financial matrix rule number 29
learn from people one of the things that
will change your life or the thing that
changes your life people ask me is it a
book that you read is that people go I
want to become an investor in general
what changes your life there's a good
book on this by Jim Collins one of the
top business writers it's luck events of
who you meet
so I goat I went to that Omaha Nebraska
investor meeting because by being around
other investors I deal in person but
when you can't do it in person it could
be through a book or through a video
that's what teaches you how to become an
investor it's not like life's not just
all about facts like okay you invest in
real estate or you invest the stock
market and automatically you make money
no it's it's more sophisticated than
that you have to pick up from people
their vibes you have to pick up their
habits their intuition that's how you
become a great investor rule number 30
help others my friend I'm gonna pay it
forward to today I got some money for
you what that's 500 bucks my friend make
sure you take care of your dog I'm gonna
buy a van I swear to god brother I'm
getting off the street your dogs eating
the shoe
trying to get off the street today yeah
man what'd you just say he said there is
a god I hope so
what what's your dog's name
whoa all right stout you have a good day
now some people for I say he might use
that money for drugs and alcohol and
there's some truth to that but I don't
know at this point of my life I don't
feel like it's my place to judge
everything figure everything out
just try to help some people use it in
the right way some people abuse it but
for the people that do use it at least
they at least people didn't hold back
giving because of the people who do
abuse it you know what I mean plus with
that guy I kind of have a soft spot for
dog he's got his dog on make sure his
dog hopefully buy some dog food vet
bills you know feel like animals are a
lot of times helpless for all you that
are successful out there count your
blessings success and fame and money is
short but
the good karma given to other people
hopefully last forever help the helpless
without too much judgement I wonder what
the world will be like if everybody all
7 billion people didn't go to sleep
until they did one and random act of
kindness
the interesting experts are better than
all the nonsense that goes on now in the
world mileage injustice what do I know
until someone figures out the answer I
guess I'll keep giving to the homeless
and the helpless I don't know
I'm no saint but feels like the right
thing to do
rule number 31 stand out with your story
people really only buy one thing they
bind his stories that's why Steve Jobs
and Apple did well people buy this story
of Apple it's like this hipster company
that it's not even what the company is
it's the largest corporation in the
world that's what it really is but they
position their story is like you know
hipster and artsy and all that and so
grit capital you got to ask yourself I
call it the brand story what's the brand
story here what's you in the brand story
has to stand out that's what I mean
about who what where when why who are we
what are we doing who what where where
can you find us when in the why the last
one is important because why is like why
you should do business with us versus
all the other sources of capital and
that's your the why is the most
important part in they're all important
but it's the most Forgotten part you go
to people's websites there is no why
we're different and people just think of
this tinder dating when you're flipping
all you're doing is looking for
differences if imagine if every tinder
profile was a blank no picture and just
said I'm a male I am you know six foot
tall I'm this age I live in this city
that's raw data you would never
go on a date with that person because
why are you different from the person
they're so good tinder profiles
differentiate so that most of your
website should be why you're different
people get it you're a capital so you're
a fund or your or your investment
helping people with capital they get
that and they've heard of that but it's
like what can you do for me lately
that's what people care about what can
you do so like if people asked like ty
what's you know what's different about
you I can sit there's different things I
can say but one of them is I'm a call I
didn't go to college I grew up in a
mobile home
I was born to raised by single mom I
lived in a you know didn't inherit a
business I went out and found five
mentors these are all unique stories
that people don't hear every day they
assume if you're doing well in business
that you went to Harvard Business School
or your parent you and your dad had a
business and then you took it over
that's not my story
by telling you this this is how you
figure that out it's very simple I call
it the waiter/waitress test every
restaurant you go to every Starbucks
barista every person sitting next to you
on the subway just start talking and
then you got a look at their pupils body
language tells you a lot when people
aren't interested they'll kind of like
okay and they'll like look at their
phone or like but if they like turn and
are like huh and if they ask you
questions that's how you really know
smart if they're like well what do you
mean by that like and so tell different
versions of the great capital story or
whoever's listening your company tell
different versions be like so I could
for example the reason I have this story
that I'm telling you now because I've
tested different parts of my life member
your life has different stories you can
tell you can tell the story when you're
8 9 10 11 12 all the way up to your
current age so we all have 50 different
stories about ourselves
you start talking every waiter or
waitress you meet which of and then you
pay attention if they always when you
tell the story number 17 if they always
go wait what then use that as your main
story that's called polling your
audience
you have to pull the audience those
entrepreneurs are doing it in the 1980s
business style where they just tell
people this is what you better like
about me now the world's too competitive
now you'll fail quickly that way so let
that's where what that's where Sam
Walton was right the customer's always
right as a group not as an individual so
if you talk to your customers and 90% of
them like story B don't tell story a
yeah so you got to get out there and
talk to strangers every business website
is like what's the least human version
of me like how can I just make it so you
don't have identify with me that's my
goal how can you not identify with me
that's what I'm gonna put on my homepage
and they'll put on a little sub page
about us and then you can scroll down
there's a little picture then if you
click on that 18 clicks later you find
this awesome story forget that good
story right on the front right here
rule number 32 find your fuel motivation
is different than purpose I'll give you
an example so if I say my purpose is to
get a million kids in the ghetto reading
books I do a lot of stuff with a reading
that's kind of one of my things
that's a purpose so that's I like to
think of purpose as vision but vision is
relatively pointless because I've never
met a person successful or very or
unsuccessful who doesn't have a vision
take your friend who never does anything
the laziest friend you have if you sit
down with them and you go what would you
like to accomplish in life they'll tell
you they'll talk for it just ask people
what they'll do if they win the lottery
the one point what's it at now only two
billion dollars I read that if you
bought 1,800 tickets a week since the
time of Christ you still today would not
have good odds that you'd win so
how 2008 that was uh some professor at
USC put that out so everybody has a
vision for what they would do if they
won the lottery but not everybody is the
motivation to get there so I think of a
GPS in my car I think of your purpose as
the end goal that you put in map your
maps so you say I'm going to the Grove
in LA so you punch in a grove that's
great but it's pointless when there's no
fuel in the car then it's just a dream
so the question becomes what is the fuel
that motivates and drives you so let's
say your thing is status you see other
people as status and you're like oh that
would be cool to walk in the room and
everybody recognizes me and stuff like
that well didn't allow yourself to go
there when you wake up in the morning
you're like I'm gonna do XYZ because one
day people are gonna know my name and I
don't know if my primary driver is
status but as I looked through my life
there's been times when there's absolute
signs that it was for example when I was
left when I was came back from the farm
back to the modern world from the Amish
I went to a night club in Raleigh North
Carolina I wish I had footage of this it
would be very funny because I went to a
night club it was the top night somebody
told me the best night club and was this
place called the office so I knew
nothing about night clubs I'd been with
the Amish okay there's no night clubs
there and I wall I just went alone a
dude just rollin up to a night club
alone if you don't have on night clubs
prestigious one they're not gonna let
you in so I go there and I'm kind of
like okay there's ropes you know they're
letting all these other people in and
I'm like okay can I go in and the dude
just like he just laughs he didn't say
anything it was like right just and I
remember thinking oh one day I'm gonna
own all these clubs and I ended up
basically running that city's nightlife
at one level so that's what I'm saying
that was status I wasn't like ooh I
wonder how much money they're making at
this place mine was like I didn't like
to be
disrespected and I've seen that over and
over in my life so now I just came to
grips with it some people are gonna like
you thinking about look at that person
you know they care about status
everything you hear you hear quotes all
the time do not you know we shouldn't
doesn't matter who you are and Don a lot
yeah a lot of those quotes aren't very
accurate the status is status is
important you know and in status is very
very powerful and if you use it for good
it's kind of like Bill Gates
he's clearly driven by money you do not
become the 17-time richest man in the
world without being hyper competitive
Paul Allen his business partner so the
two most competitive people I've met in
my life
Michael Jordan and Bill Gates and Bill
Gates
you better believe he cares about money
but yet he's turned and harnessed that
into the charity that's in some ways
maybe done more good than all
governmental organizations for the last
hundred years so that's why I say he's
been able to pull it off and if each of
you could find your version of that for
some of you it's like you pulled up in a
car and everybody laughed at you and you
know and you're like one day I'm gonna
pull up on a nice car when I get out
this car people gonna look at me and be
like Bob's here Susie's here and in a
suit you don't have to feel guilty for
it that's my main thing as long and I
think I won't have time to go through
this but as long as you start filling so
this is the selfish side we started
talking about as honor you start filling
up the unselfish side it will offset the
negative connotations that society has
okay with whatever drives you rule
number 33 turn negatives into positives
I was in a crib and two adults were
yelling but my mom came in the crib and
was like it's okay and my mom I could
remember my mom crying so my very
earliest memory as a human is
instability my dad was like a big he was
a pro bodybuilder it's a big strong guy
and I would tell people about my dad
like he was still in my life I never
told them because they'd be like well
where's your dad and I'd be like oh he's
busy he can't come but the truth was he
was
didn't care that much my mom says hi
when I was pregnant with you
FBI kicked down the door with guns put
guns in my face took your dad away and
brought them across the country to
Terminal Island off Long Beach I
remember was my birthday my dad when he
got out of prison he he just stayed in
Long Beach but for that birthday my
dad's like I will drive down and take
you out to dinner and he said he'd be
there at like 5:00 p.m. and she had to
go to work
she had a night shift job and she's like
okay your dad will be here soon so I'm
gonna leave you out the house alone so I
sat there I was kind of on the couch and
I remember waiting for my dad and it was
like 5:30 came nothing six nothing we
had a home landline like waiting for the
phone to ring seven eight I remember
being like super sad going but you're a
little kid so you're like I'll have
hopefully he's still gonna come he's
just late he's just lately just late I
don't remember how long it was but my
mom said she came home at midnight I was
just asleep like literally like on the
couch just like looking out the window
and he never came and so I remember that
being like super painful and being just
like my dad doesn't care about me life
will throw tremendous blows at you
you'll have the betrayal of a close
friend or family member you'll have you
know sickness death life is painful if I
perceive it as what it was supposed to
be but the second I switch it and go
wait no life's like a puzzle that I was
handed here's your puzzle light of life
tie we took a piece out the dad was gone
and when I look at life like that my
life's like an adventure and I'm
thankful for even the stuff that sucked
in the most painful day and sometimes in
the moment I couldn't see it there but
in hindsight I'm like but I wouldn't
have found that puzzle piece
rule number 34 leave your comfort zone
what a Drake say if you don't have
haters you're not poppin if you just
start doing stuff you start posting that
person you thought the friend or like oh
why you got to show off well you got to
show off that's the person that you kick
out of the circle people should either
be giving you constructive criticism
they don't always have to
approve everything either constructive
or they should be nice you don't need
anything else in that circle you will
make the average of the five closest
people to you that's an old saying guess
your five closest friends income is the
average friend make it 30 to 40 and
you're making 50 so you're the best one
in the group you don't want to be the
best one in the bubble you want this
bubble to be full of people that
intimidate you all growth comes from
being intimidated if you're always
feeling comfortable comfort comes from
being from status right you feel good
around your friends you know your status
with them you're comfortable when you go
under group you know if right now Elon
Musk
Mark Zuckerberg all these people walked
into this room and said come to dinner
with us we're all gonna chat about
business gonna share you you might be
like oh I don't know what I'm gonna do I
don't have anything to contribute good
that's the room you want to be in rule
number 35 think big think big my mind's
still running through all the
conversations I had with Arnold
Schwarzenegger last night in his kitchen
talked to him for about an hour's one of
the greatest conversations I've ever had
and that's one of the takeaways I think
big you know he told me he said he
always thought big he said don't worry
about failure so much died how far can
you really fall we're all only a few
feet from the ground and I was thinking
mentors you know he told me about his
mentor reg Park his first mentor and I
thought that's what's wrong in the world
that's why it's so easy to feel lost who
do we have guiding our way you know you
got to go out you have to find people
you have to find people who have done it
before who can shorten the path who can
keep you from failure he told me he said
don't fail too much one of the reasons
he doesn't procrastinate and can think
big he said is because he he at 20 years
old won mr. Olympia so he said he got
used to success and he tasted success
and so you know make sure you find some
little wins in life don't always lose
it's a myth that you only want to learn
from mistakes what are you gonna from
the states they don't have to be yours
though people in the modern world with
all this convenience we have the next
thing
no all you're doing is just sitting
around not accomplishing anything you
know go out conquer the world conquer
your fears
think big that's all I could think you
know he's a big dude strong but his life
was big made some mistakes made a lot of
great attempts and successes rule number
36 recreate your life and nobody in my
family had ever really made money and
you know they say poverty is systemic
and it's true like most people you can't
rise out of like your socio-economic
class like one of the biggest predictors
of where you'll be in life is where
you're born it sucks
breaking the cycle is something that has
to start happening in the world and what
broke the cycle for me was like
realizing that I was doing it wrong I
was in a mobile home in Clayton North
Carolina and I did not have a job I
didn't have a resume I didn't have
anything to put on a resume I didn't
have a college degree just laying there
on the couch and when I was laying there
the question that came in my head was is
this it all my friends went to college
they had parents that have more money
and they had this and like I missed this
I remember just going to sleep I was
just depressed and the next day my mom
was there and she said you should read
this book Tony Robbins and I remember
being like oh I don't want some
self-help book but she's like yeah you
should read the book so I read it and I
don't remember that much what I read but
I remember the one-page and it said all
greatness starts with failure because
when you succeed you party and when you
fail you ponder and all greatness comes
from pondering your situation I remember
thinking that's what I was doing last
night on the couch I was like pondering
like what did I do wrong and and I made
myself vulnerable to the fact that maybe
I did make mistakes maybe I had to
change my life maybe had to listen to
different people maybe I did try
path you know Einstein said the
definition of insanity is doing the same
thing over and over but expecting
different results and I'm like ty you're
being stubborn so after I read that book
I was like I'm gonna try something new
so I went back in that mobile home I
found the yellow pages and I remember
flipping through it going to the
financial section and there was this
full-page ad by this guy Mike Stainback
it said Stainback financial services and
I kind of pretended I didn't lie but I
kind of pretended I was coming there to
be a customer and I get to the place and
I'm like I'm Ty can I speak to your boss
and I'll never forget he was sitting
like this like gum big like lazy boy
chair and he had this big moustache he
looked like Tom Selleck I wanted to be
super honest with him I said listen Mike
you don't know who I am but I know you
must be successful because you've got a
full-page ad in the yellow pages that's
all I know about you but I know that
costs a lot of money if you teach me
what you know about making money I'll
work for you for free and he was sitting
like in this charity he was I was
talking to him this way and he was
sideways and he just slowly pivoted his
chair you know I've been looking for
someone like you for 20 years you come
back in the morning and I'll set you up
with your own office and you can work
for me and I promise you if you listen
to what I must say one day you'll hug my
neck and he did have an office but what
he had done was he cleaned out a closet
with no windows and he had put a desk
it's where all the filing cabinets was i
sat down on the chair and he plopped
down pieces of paper and said Cole call
these people I'll give you a percentage
of the money you make from them no
guarantees working for me
so I just started calling and I sucked
at it I would coffee bought six you know
after six at night they were like
overview they were hanging up on me I
remember being like oh no I think I've
gone from nightmare to another nightmare
but I started to get curious and
creative and I wrote down a few little
different things I would say to the
people and I remember in that first
month I started opening up deals for
this might stain background I opened a
deal that was one hundred and fifty
thousand dollars in commissions if the
deal went through and I remember going
wow life can change like fast it within
nine months I went from zero dollars to
making a hundred grand I remember being
like this is the pinnacle of my life and
I went out from then like a madman I
became a CFP a certified financial
planner I got into finance I learned I
read every book you can either be
paralyzed by what life gave you and let
the pain because there will be pain that
will be drama you can either let it
build up and like build scar tissue that
that just paralyzes you or at some point
you go the cars didn't weren't dealt for
me like I wanted and so I'm gonna go
recreate those cards rule number 37 debt
knowledge so just knowing stuff makes
you go up and if you studies status and
psychology being stupid lowers you on
the totem pole I once went on a date
with a girl one of the most beautiful
girls in Los Angeles I'll never forget I
was in Santa Monica I was at a
restaurant and I was like we're just
talking and I was like yeah I got to go
to Miami next week and she goes Miami
where is that I've heard of it and I was
like oh my god this is American - she's
like Miami I've heard of that she's like
is that Northern California so would you
do that no matter how you look nobody
respects somebody that's stupid does
that make sense you don't have to be
Albert Einstein but you can't be dumb
and most people are dumb you read 52
books a year I promise you your status
in other people's eyes will go up
naturally without you trying it without
you forcing it
rule number 38 does
of success to get what you want you have
to deserve what you want the world's not
yet a crazy enough place to reward a
whole bunch of undeserving people and a
lot of people think Oh world's not fair
and that's true a lot of things in the
world aren't fair but I will tell you
this in general if you're good at
something you will rise at the top it
might take a little while for people to
recognize your talent but most people
give up a year too early so at the end
of the day my philosophy is you can be
entitled you can expect things you can
just think you deserve them you can be
like hey you know and a lot of people
are like that in the model world they're
too entitled or you can just go out and
say I will make it I will force the
universe to give me what I want you know
and that works with making money
that works about in every area of life
and every time my life doesn't go as
expected it's because I don't really
deserve what I'm wanting rule number 39
used a law of 33% I just spoke on this
subject that I think is like the
ultimate puzzle piece you get this down
most your problems go away I called the
law of 33% basically you should spend
33% of your day around people who have
not accomplished what you've
accomplished yet you can help them like
you mentor them and there's always those
people and you need to spend time around
people that you can help and then you
spend 33 percent of your time around
people who are on your level like you're
about at the same level of a cop of what
you're trying to do
those are your become your close friends
you know those are the people you hang
out with on the weekend
but the last 33% is the magical one that
doesn't happen in our school system and
almost no one even tries to find these
people unfortunately there's been 33
percent of your time around people who
are 5 10 20 30 years ahead where you
want to be and if you do the math you
know that's like a couple hours a day
and now you can do with YouTube video so
you can do it with a book you can do it
with an audio book you can do a face in
books videos if you can start absorbing
from the world's greatest line download
their advice into your body there are 40
years of experience in pain and reward
in making mistakes in accomplishing
great things in you can you basically
get like a cheat sheet and if you can
absorb that and this is what I tell
myself every day I wake up it's like
Thai law 33% we spending time with rule
number forty support others
how long you been playing
there you go man
there's a hundred bucks no problem keep
playing the world needs more art always
support street musicians the world needs
more art music beauty you agree on that
rule number 41 no what motivates you you
spent two years living with the Amish
the Amish yeah how did you wind up
moving from two years of the Amish to
you know multi-million dollars here 500
acres over in Virginia and yeah if
people off would say they're like cuz I
did a video 2014-2015 with I had bought
a Lamborghini and I posted it and it
ended up I think the total views there's
a few versions of it is six hundred
million views on YouTube it's one most
viewed things besides music videos right
so people are like hatch end up from no
electricity living like that for two
years to ever the hills and I'm like I
have no idea actually but life has lead
you down a path that you don't always
understand except in hindsight so I
guess in hindsight I'm motivated by
adventure one of the things a mentor
taught me is this thing that I call the
four M's
a lot of people procrastinate if you
bump into most people I meet I've got
about 13 million social media followers
now so I get thousands of people asking
me questions every day and the most
common theme one of the most common is
how do I overcome procrastination fear
and anxiety my answer is like well you
got to know what motivates you and
different people are motivated in
different ways so the four M's and I've
run this by a lot of scientists most of
them think I'm on the right track one of
them just he thinks I'm missing an M but
the first M is material things might
slash money the second one is mating
slash romance the third one is momentum
slash freedom and and the fourth one is
mastery slash status if you look at any
person that you know and you break down
why do they do what they do it's one of
those four rule number forty to catch
trends my second mentor Allen nation who
just died recently rest in peace he
changed my
um he was my first venture Joel
Salatin's mentor mentor introduced me to
his mentor put me on an accelerated path
and first thing he told me so ty if you
say an idea of yours and your next-door
neighbor likes it it's too late it's too
late to make money with that once it's
accepted by the masses it's no longer a
new trend and the only people making
money from it are the people who got in
early you gotta learn to get in early if
you're cynical if you're stubborn if
you're slow if you're set in your ways
if you're not adaptable you're gonna
have a hard time doubling your income
you're gonna have a hard time ever
achieving real financial freedom you can
be a slave to the system you gonna be a
slave to the nine-to-five I remember I
want part of my life doing I wonder if I
can ever make thousand dollars a month
from a non nine-to-five job then I
figure out how to make a thousand bucks
a month I remember making six figures
ten grand a month and going man I make
it more money than anyone in my family's
paid you know for the last 50 years
maybe longer my dad's from Harlem dad my
grandfather worked in a subway didn't
have money you know you don't work in a
subway if you got a lot of money and he
was a mechanic no offense to being a
mechanic a subway I'm just saying he was
living paycheck to paycheck and so as I
go through this and I start thinking
like what did Steve Jobs do of course
alan nation was right Steve Jobs
presented the idea of the personal
computer so I think it was Stanford all
these Ivy League professors who were so
smart
they laughed out but you know what guess
who laughed all the way to the bank
Steve Jobs Bill Gates Mark Zuckerberg
Elon Musk you see you have to have thick
skin that allows you to catch new trends
that allows you to see what most people
don't see so you need to be you know
I'll give you a practical bit of advice
you should be checking Google Trends
every day it's a free service by Google
you literally just google the phrase
Google Trends go look what's trending
around the world
red bull the energy drink formed by
I think an Austrian guy was now one of
the richest people in the world you know
what he did he traveled the world he
caught trends in Asia they had this
sugary drink that was successful there
he brought it to Europe
boom caught a trend and then he put in
the effort there's some other things you
have to do I'm just rolling back I'm
revealing the secrets one by one right
down trend catcher Nike rule number 43
live in the now
that book by Eckhart Tolle called the
power of now it's interesting I never
loved that book because people use the
power of now to mean they're really it's
people have taken it to mean like
meditation and stuff like that which is
fine I'm not anti meditation but you
can't meditate unless you're the Dalai
Lama ten hours a day not really a
solution I think what the power of now
means is just not thinking about the
future not thinking about the past kind
of like these horses these horses not
thinking very far ahead and horses are
pretty happy please these ones are doc
Duke you happy Jerry Jake
they're learning their names actually no
but they're just in the moment so I
think it's less about meditation is more
about doing activities can be a garden
if you live in a city it can be taking
care of animals dogs rule number 44 use
the law of 33% I did a TEDx talk and it
kind of went viral and I think the
reason was I told people if you want to
do big things in life you have to follow
this thing I call the law 33 percent so
you spend 33 percent of your time around
people with less accomplishment with you
those are people maybe you mentor you
help right then you spend 33 percent a
time around people who on your level
those become your friends people who
smoke cigars with or bubble cigars when
the last 33% is what's missing in
education in society that's where you
spend 33 percent of your time around
people 20 years ahead of you shadowing
them and I want some a few years ago I
made a list like everybody that you
think of as great people Albert Einstein
and Hawking Bill Gates Mark Zuckerberg
Jeff Bezos Warren Buffett and I was like
there for some of them went to college
but I was like what's a common thread
that they all have in it and found out
that Albert Einstein bumped into this
guy I think his name was max Levinson
who was a mathematician an older
mathematician every Thursday he would go
to lunch and talk math with this guy
from age 16 on Alexander the Great who
maybe was the greatest Conqueror of all
time his dad hired a mentor for him at
age I think 14 to 16 and a pretty good
mentor his name was Aristotle and you
know Warren Buffett got a guy named
Benjamin Graham and as I went through
the list I found in the top 40 people
that you could say have done big things
in our time
I think 39 of them attribute a lot of
their success to Mentors they don't
attribute it to oh I took a social
studies class
oh I'm er eyes things in seventh grade
they attributed as somebody who kind of
held their hand in and and they shadowed
through education process ruler 45 take
action talk is cheap action is what
matters
people man oh boy almond absorbs a lot
and I hear it every day I got 13 million
social media followers I get thousands
of denote ah you're gonna hear from me
I'm gonna do the next video uh usually
the more people talk the less they do
not always sometimes people talk and do
but a lot of times people use talking as
a excuse to procrastinate more and more
and more rule number 46 reinforce good
habits one of my favorite quotes is the
chains of habit are too weak to be felt
until they're too strong to be broken so
anybody heard that before raise your
hand if you heard that Warren Buffett
says it I'm not sure who originally came
up with it but the chains a habit are
too weak to be felt till they're too
strong to be broken so we are all kinds
of Ages here levels of entrepreneurs and
life really I've evolved or tried to
evolve through different phases of being
an entrepreneur whether it be oh I
started when I was 19 years old
Joel Salatin
and I was on his farm and I said Joel
there's this guy that has a a ranch next
to you and Joel said and I said we could
rent he said he'd give us the land for
free to use and Joel said no we're too
busy here on on his farm 500 acre farm I
said well I'll take care of it and he
said well you're busy here working from
5:00 in the morning to 5:00 a knife on
this farm and I said yeah but I'll get a
little headlamp you know those little
headlamp things you see people and I'll
do all my work on the farm then I'll
Drive over to this other four it was
actually about 45 minutes way I'll Drive
over and take care of that farm and so I
did that for nine months and then we
sold the cows that we raised and so my
first business I made $12,000 in nine
months so I made about when you do the
hourly it didn't make I didn't do very
well but what it was doing was
reinforcing a habit or a pattern that
when you go out and do something it
succeeds and so that's why I was saying
the chains a habit a lot of people for
varying reasons as entrepreneurs they
fail a lot at the beginning which starts
to create habits of the mind patterns of
the mind expectations of the mind and
then they become like chains that are
too hard to break rule number 47 learn
the right things Charlie Munger says
don't try to think out how to have a
good life
he says use the principle of inversion
try to think how to have a bad life and
then don't do that
so guys you want to have a bad life for
every hundred dollars you make save one
or two of them and spend 98 and so I
grew up you know I was born to a single
mom my dad was actually in prison when I
was born I was born kind of an inner
city in Long Beach and growing up until
I met these mentors I was just kind of
floating around yes you're in school and
but they don't teach anything about
making money it just has to be the
biggest oversight in the solar system
it's like why do you go to school at the
core practical value because you have to
provide for yourself and your family for
the next 40 50 years do we equip you
with any skills for that no we did you
calculus which will help you if you
become an engineer which I remember
was in his class I remember learning in
seventh grade they made me memorize what
the California state bird was Cal I
think it's the California condor if I
remember correctly right um but I was
thinking then when I was like 25 I
learned how to invest in real estate and
stock mark and I was thinking I could
have waited on the California State like
I feel like you can learn that at 60 and
you'll still have an enriched life but
you may want to teach kids before
they're 18 like how to do their taxes
how to invest how to do real estate how
to sign a contract there's zero of that
in school even in college I hire PhDs
that are just morons or actually don't
hire my interview and I'm thinking get
your money back son there's there's one
there's depend on who you ask there's
1.2 trillion dollars of recorded debt
for college in the United States and
they think if you can't untracked loans
from parents we're talking two trillion
dollars in debt
and people are coming out knowing
nothing common sense is no longer common
you know and so how does a society
survive that doesn't know how to take
care of themselves it ends up in a
government state that becomes a solution
rule number 48 study the outliers when I
began to study both I had five
millionaire mentors over a series of
years got dropped out of college I had
no money will sleep on a couch mobile
back to the mobile home again no college
degree no future didn't have a car
didn't even have a suit to interview for
a job no qualifications for a regular
mainstream job I'd I've spent seven
years on a farm so I only had farm
qualifications I'm at the end of my rope
and then I said wait a sec I'm gonna
start researching cuz there are a few
people the one out of a hundred people
that pull themselves out of it what do
they do different you got to study
people that they call outliers
you can't just study the mass
the masses has always been wrong the
masses or you know look at science
gravity Sir Isaac Newton or Leonardo da
Vinci or people that were ahead of their
time Martin Luther King jr. Gandhi these
people are criticized scorned oftentimes
murdered by the masses the masses are
almost always wrong so I said I forget
the masses I'm gonna look at the one and
in a million or the one in a hundred
that pulls it off
rule number 49 change your mindset
[Music]
I don't know who made that video and I
don't want to oversimplify the subject
but I'll tell you from somebody who's
been poor and I've been rich that
perception is everything what you
perceived to be impossible you will
never even attempt and it will become
harder and harder what you perceive to
be easy will become easier and easier
and the reason the rich stay richer is
because they've seen someone else to do
it maybe their parents or a mentor and
the reason the poor stay poor is they've
never seen it done so it seems
impossible change your mindset change
your bank account and rule number 50 the
last one in for a very special bonus
clip is get outdoors you know what's
better than Lamborghini a real horse
you've got real horsepower there's more
than one horsepower just like Ferraris
the horse goodbye city and that by the
river can you hear it that's the best
sound
[Applause]
right here is where I want to build a
house look at this house site that's the
Appalachian Trail over there now you
never want to build on top of a hill
completely because of the wind the views
are beautiful hardly walk now I've got a
special bonus cup from Ty on how to
reverse engineer success that I think
you're going to enjoy but before that
it's time for the three-point landing
questions let's go from just watching
the video to taking action here we go
question number one who are three
outliers that you are going to study
number two how will you reward yourself
so you reinforce good habits a number
three what's the mindset shift that you
need to make you have to go out and find
people who are successful financially
and reverse engineer what they did
reverse engineer REI keep that little
acronym in my head
it's one of the most powerful acronyms
that you can remember are e reverse
engineer so for example when I was
starting out I was like what would it
take to become a millionaire and I go
alright
win the lottery a lot of people play the
lottery and then some people one or two
become millionaires but if you reverse
engineer I asked myself this one day I
started study what makes the most
millionaires what's made the most
millionaires and the United States
self-made not people who inherited their
money and the answer is tada
real estate now you don't even have to
be trying to make a million dollars
every time a millionaire but just think
about that reverse engineer that and put
it into your life it's not
about a career but it's about also
passive income because your careers
active income you work on your career
you go to your job even if you're an
entrepreneur right but what about when
you're asleep here's a crazy statistic
if you just listen to this person if you
make what's minimum wage let's say let's
just say fifteen bucks an hour that's
thirty thousand dollars a year right
but what happens if you make fifteen
dollars an hour
24/7 okay now that's ninety thousand
dollars a year triple it but you can't
work 24 hours a day so that means you
have to have this thing called passive
income and passive income means I locked
myself in my own living room here
well god this way I was filming over
here so what I started doing is going I
gotta have my active income job career
entrepreneurship but I want to reverse
engineer the passive income that the
most millionaires have ever the most
what has created the most millionaires
ever sorry and that's real estate if you
want Tai Lopez's advice on how to make a
hundred thousand dollars a year check
out the video right there next to me I
think you'll enjoy it continue to
believe and I'll see you there and I'm
gonna share with you four simple steps
that you can get started making money
online today